The Buddhist psychology tradition in
particular and the Asian psychologies in
general,
and actually the engine Christian
monastic psychology's do have a strong
theory and a strong practice really,
uh,
of overcoming bitterness,
hatred,
resentment,
vengefulness and so forth.
Carrying a little further for Moses has
already restraining idea of an eye for
an eye and tooth for tooth.
In other words,
you don't take a leg or a life for an
eye,
you know,
or a life for it too.
It's,
you know,
just enough to do this,
which was already a step forward from
the old engines idea of tribal attitude
and a,
and Jesus has in Buddha's greater idea
of really love your enemies and how to
unpack that in a modern city.
And people get nervous about it because
they think if you love your enemies,
your meat,
it means you're going to cave to them.
You're going to be a martyr.
You're going to invite them to come and
destroy you and just be a masochist
sense of what.
And that is not at all.
But it means love means in the Asian
psychological term that I think really
in any term means the wish for the
beloved happiness to want to make the
one you love happy.
That's what love really is.
It isn't really greeted,
wished to possess,
although some kinds of loves tend to
tend to mix with that of the egotistical
person.
The reason someone is your enemy is they
think you are preventing their
happiness.
Somehow you have something they want,
you're in their way.
Whatever it is.
The world isn't big enough for the both
of you type of attitude.
And so they want to be your enemy and
because they are unhappy and they think
by getting rid of you,
they will be happy.
So if they were happy already without
messing with you,
they might be wanting to leave you alone
because it's no fun to go attack people.
It's like a,
it's,
it's an exercise,
you know,
it's not like giving a caress or
receiving what so,
so loving your enemies is actually
practical advice.
And Martin Luther King,
for example,
when he went back the second time,
that bridge in Birmingham,
a John Lewis says that he,
he was advised by his friends,
come on,
like,
don't get into how are we going to love
those guys,
those cops who were sicking dogs and the
hoses and beating us and jailing us and
torturing us and that then Martin Luther
said,
no,
uh,
Martin Luther King's that no,
it's too bitter.
A burden to bear hatred and resentment.
We do love them.
Of course we opposed them and we're
against them and we don't want them to
behave like that,
but we don't hate them.
That's just a ridiculous waste of our
energy.
And in a way,
you can see that being an enemy who has
hurt you has already hurt you.
If you go around nursing hatred and
vindictiveness and how to get back at
them,
you're hurting yourself.
When you oppose your enemy who someone,
and,
and by,
by saying your enemies,
someone,
they think they're your enemy.
Hopefully if you love your enemy,
you have no enemy.
But if you,
when you oppose that person,
which you could do,
you could have tough love.
You can have fierce compassion and when
they sense that you're doing it because
you want their betterment actually,
cause it's not good them to be mean to
you and so on,
then actually it has a little different
edge to it.
And for example,
if you're trying to get them to see
reason,
there's a better chance they'll be able
to listen to you when they don't feel
the weight of hatred and a destructive
vibration toward them coming through the
speech.
They know what's in the style and the
energy of his speech.
Your motivation will make it more
successful.